[Music]
all right frozen [ __ ] christ have a
headache now what now
okay so
he said something about filler right uh
yeah sure
shawl links
hold on
what is this movie called
oh a movie it's a reality tv show what
is this show called
snowflake mountain
is it snowflake like
like snowflake like the
like what disco like you're triggered
these guys are just snowflakes man
they're marks
[Music]
i need my foundation i need my lip gloss
oh my god
which one's the mountain is she the
mountain yeah
it looks like her cleavage is getting
vomited out of her top
i need my lip gloss i need my highlight
and my contour oh my god why do you have
your boobs like
that it looks like a butt
snowflake a young person who's
considered overly emotional
easily offended [ __ ] you guys this is
not okay and dramatic this is the worst
thing that's ever happened to me this is
great by the way this is the nxt guy
right
um this is the woken xt guy what's that
guy one the one who for some reason they
have braun breaker and they're setting
up one of the [ __ ] biggest losers
there oh joe gacy yeah just joe gacy
first off
don't
okay don't do what you're trying to do
all right this sucks don't do what donny
don't does the only way i'll watch this
if they actually kill them if they lose
in my whole
life
brav
no cap bruv
there's a heap of young adult zucchini
oh my god
they got uh what's his face uh from the
young
turks hassan they got yeah they got them
they got they got a son
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] is this guy
so you can't even unload a dishwasher
let alone hold down a job
and these ten snowflakes families have
reached their breaking point so they've
tricked their giant babies into
traveling far far away to make them grow
the hell they trick them what if they
just leave you can't kidnap people yeah
you can't like they had to sign a
contract too of course
you can't just they had to sign a
release there's all these legal
documents you have to sign they have to
tell you where they're taking we're
taking all these black snowflakes back
to africa wait what what
what is show is this it's called based
mountain
where the hell are we i feel like i'm on
a [ __ ] pilgrimage
and that's where we come in who are
these guys we're gonna hunt them oh i'm
joel this is my buddy matt i was an army
combat engineer for almost 10 years
and we're gonna be uh hunting them with
live ammunition bro
i know you're kidding but you would
watch that right i would watch that
every day
with this show to watch
i would become homeless as long as i had
my as long as i had my netflix so i
could watch that show if this one's got
a cracked smartphone yeah
just hunting young millennials i'm
former navy explosive ordnance disposal
it's basically the bomb squad think hurt
locker
now oh the bomb squad that's going to be
the name of brenden shops next special
they should put together like like all
the worst comedians and call them the
bomb squad i love that
margaret cho brendan schaub
kathy griffin somebody has a good idea
in the chat what if we used bows to hunt
them instead that would be more that'd
be more fun i agree yeah who survived
all the hunting [ __ ] zoomers and our
whole lives are going to take these kids
back to basics hurry up
why
because the wilderness forces you to
toughen up
feels borderline abusive
okay signed up for this here's the other
problem on that don't you hate when they
try to make you think like this is not a
scripted reality show but then they make
them do scenes like this ernest forces
you to toughen up do the home alone
well come on man
i hate this guy everything about this
guy he's in raging i just i think he
bites him no but i think it's just
because he looks like a song
i think you're right oh my god i think
you're right
i i honestly think you're right i think
that's why i hate him you're right
because there's a lot of cool dudes that
look like this but you need him now and
you're like ah
he looks like a son he's probably a
[ __ ]
turns out this one is one
borderline abusive
are they going to rise to the challenge
just so you know i just [ __ ] in a paint
bucket
or are they yeah you've never been to
coachella yeah
you've never been a music festival
they're gonna do what they do best i'm
not doing that no way don't wait
melt
down
i can see it now i hate her breast
oh my god
her tits look like fudgy the whale from
carvel
she looks like lizzo trying to squeeze
into a regular coach seat on an airplane
i hate it
i'm gonna get a rash a [ __ ] rash
ugh
i don't need to know that ma'am i gotta
hear that again though
i hear that one again let's feel let's
go here
i can see it now i'm gonna get a rash a
[ __ ] rash
soccer bees we don't know if they can do
it i just can't do it
because i'm vegan
well then just die i guess i mean please
i don't care
that's the one thing i am looking
forward to society collapsing is like
the vegans
it's gonna be so much fun watching them
try to sustain themselves
and you're gonna be like oh yeah you
haven't eaten in three days well i
killed this rabbit
i'm gonna make some rabbit you want to
eat some rabbit and i guarantee you
they're gonna eat that [ __ ] cute
little bunny
i might cry i just don't know if carrion
would be the right thing they might die
we're actually nice guys
no you're not we just don't like black
people
that's it
he's like yeah it's okay girl i got you
he's a 9.
you're right he has a pro he has a
burberry headband don't worry girl i got
you i'm a [ __ ]
and then if they throw a spider and he
screams like a girl and runs away
and then he knocks her up and by the
time they get done filming and get back
to society roe v wade is overturned
[Music]
i won't be around why are you like this
frozen
what do you mean
it's friday we're supposed to leave
happy like not sad well i'm happy we're
the one that created this stupid bit
yeah but i
i know where the you guys are the
geniuses that came up with let's make
frozen make us miserable for the last 15
minutes of the week who's the adwords
that came up with that one huh that was
you nah i don't think so that was
definitely you we replaced excuse me
what with let's get purposely angry
before we get into a friday night yeah
but like okay buddy but like but here's
the thing